[Music]
i get the question all the time
wasn't it wonderful in 1947 jackie
robinson breaks the color barrier
opens up major league baseball to
everyone my answer has to be
no it wasn't it was actually more
difficult for african-american
ballplayers
many talented black players got phased
out
racism ended my professional career
the primary reason for the end of the
negro leagues
is integration what we saw with the
negro leagues
and particularly those negro league
teams that were
in close proximity to major league teams
they died in almost instant death
because that black fan base left to go
see jackie
to go see larry dobey we're trying to
get to the major leagues and once that
was an option
these segregated teams and leagues were
abandoned completely
in the 50s the indianapolis clowns
dropped out of the negro american league
now all the great players they've been
signed a major league
folks that own the teams and that were
very smart individuals they knew
baseball
but they also knew business did pollock
abe saperstein
who both had business interests in the
harlem globetrotters
hired women to play for the indianapolis
clowns
surprising that i've seen women playing
in any eager leagues
they could play tony stone was the first
woman to play for the indianapolis
clowns
she's followed by mimi peanut johnson
and
connie morgan who competed against the
men in the 1950s
was it a promotional gimmick yes was it
successful
yes they were trying to get people to
the ballparks
and at the same time they're selling
their best players
to the major leagues trying to fill the
role of all these lost ball players
and it really doesn't work and if it did
work for some teams it only worked
maybe four or five years unfortunately
just because
jackie robinson integrated baseball that
didn't
change the fact that it was going to be
very difficult for young black ball
players
before i leave this earth somebody out
there know the answer
why is it at that time they were
drafting
black men to go fight and die
for this country but they didn't want us
to play baseball
for this country black men
helped build this country history
isn't always necessarily pretty and
it's not always as glamorous as people
would like it to be
there were a lot of guys that never got
the opportunity
to go beyond minor league baseball
there's no question that there was a
quota system in place
when that first group of black players
transitioned into the major leagues
i had the fortune of knowing a gentleman
by the name of bobby break
bobby was the manager for the pittsburgh
pirates at the time
he was very honest with me he said we
had a quota system back in those days
you couldn't have more than four black
ball players on your team in the story
and that was pushing it i wanted to make
it to the major league
i thought i was going to make it with my
speed and hidden
because i could hit 1950s jake gets
signed by the brooklyn dodgers
organization
they sent him to minor league training
camp he has a phenomenal
training camp leading hitter on the team
starting outfielder
they make the cuts for the season jake's
one of the first ones that get cut
why do you cut the best baseball player
on your team
that's what hurt me so bad when they cut
me
for a white kid then 264 and i'm about
to
clean up i was serious about the game
but it's one of those things pedro
played everywhere
you can play professional baseball he
played in the negro leagues he played
in minor league baseball he played in
canada he played dominican republic he
played in mexico
i don't have any regrets of what
happened i thought i'd think to myself
you know that i that i could have played
and those who
played around me knew that i could when
i got in professional baseball
i didn't realize just how bad
racism was ernest got to play
in the st louis cardinals organization
the next year
i was traded to the kansas city
that's when racism set in
my own teammate they didn't even want me
to sit on the bench water
now the people understand i could take
that
and keep walking but my whole teammate
it bothered me because i felt that
baseball for everybody
they figured i'll get discouraged and
quit
but i showed them i could play anywhere
on a baseball field so what they started
doing
they would make up excuses to make sure
no other team signed you they said
you play your music too loud man
i wasn't making enough money to buy
stereo
radio if america
truly appreciated the greatest athletes
there wouldn't have been
a negro league there wouldn't have been
an all-white major league
and then we would have truly seen the
greatest baseball players of all time
those aren't the truly greatest numbers
because they didn't include the truly
greatest players
the husband said oh we don't have the
stats but i
found scorebooks i found in some of the
black newspapers they kept scoring a
tally
since 1947 think of all the records that
have fallen
related to african-american baseball
players that didn't have to start in
1947
it could have started in 1907 it could
have started
in 1887. so baseball history would be
changed
but we will never know how much
[Music]
but this story the crux of it looks at
a story that is about the importance of
economic empowerment it is a story about
an
unprecedented level of leadership that
emerged
as a result of the formation of these
leagues
black coaches black owners black
executives
they were done once the negro leagues
died and we don't hear about them what
what would it mean
if black kids didn't just want to be the
next satchel page or josh gibson but
they wanted to be the next gus greenlee
or the next epham manly one of the
things i
would like to see happen is that it
would be in
schools because the negro league
accomplished a lot of things
other than just baseball the negro
league
made not only black history american
history
and all of that is wrapped around this
amazing story of these very courageous
athletes who as i like to say forged a
glorious history
in the midst of an inglorious time in
american history
to play the game they love we don't want
people to forget about josh gibson and i
was just josh gibson people forget about
the negro leagues
so what we're trying to do is keep this
legacy alive is through the job skips
and foundations making sure that the
youth is educated
on the negro leagues as well as making
sure they get the right education to
further the education so we have a job
skipping scholarships we have a job
curriculum it teaches kids the business
side of sports sports media sports law
sports marketing for sales
[Music]
when we built the negro leagues baseball
museum 30 years ago
we knew then that it was literally a
race against time
that those who had created this history
it wasn't a matter of if it was simply a
matter when we were going to lose them
and that it was so vitally important
that their story
and their legacy would play on long
after
there were no negro league players to
attest
to the greatness of these leagues a lot
of the researchers are getting older
like myself
you know i'm 70 years old and it's
tremendously gratifying to me that
there's someone there to carry on this
legacy
as we celebrate the 100th anniversary of
the negro leagues major league baseball
has made a commitment to also honor the
new colleagues
back in august they all were the
centennial patch there's been
several major league baseball teams who
recognize january league baseball
players
milwaukee brewers has celebrated the
negro leagues pittsburgh pirates
atlanta braves kansas city royals
chicago
white sox detroit tigers by either
bringing some of these players back to
honor them or just having some kind of
exhibit to showcase their fans
right now i'm trying to get young kids
back interested in baseball i coach
little league team i talk to kids
[Music]
what the negro leagues teaches us is
quite simple in this
country of ours if you dare to dream
and you believe in yourself you can do
or be anything you want to be
and if we were able to accomplish what
we were able to accomplish in 1920 with
far less resources what are we capable
of now
i think the legacy honestly is that we
are more powerful
than we know they had no idea they were
making history they didn't care
about making history they just wanted to
play ball
[Music]
you